personnellement je déteste les mecs
musclés ça m'énerve c'est tout c'est pas
du tout de la jalousie
ok ok c'est la jalousie
en fait ce qui m'énerve c'est que les
mecs musclés dans certaines situations
et nous créer complexe tu vas chez nous
les mecs pas très musclé ça fait chaud
rajat gupta non j'ai pas j'ai pas tout à
fait les mecs musclés il met pas les
mêmes genres de t-shirts que tu as à y
mettre des t-shirts fait pour qu'on voit
le plus possible leur musculature le mec
même son téton et mouler des fois il met
carrément des t-shirts filet pour qu'on
voit à travers les mythes autant rien
mettre du tout cas ce genre de t-shirts
tu peux les mettre seulement cité
musclée c'est ce que tu veux sortir avec
moi
dommage on sait tous pourquoi les mecs
musclés se muscle veut dire oh là on
n'est pas bête
on sait que voilà c'est toujours pour la
même raison en fait pourquoi tu as
commencé à la muscu qu'est ce qui t'a
motivé pour mon bien-être pour mon
équilibre juste en équilibre des capotes
heureusement que toutes les filles sont
pas comme ça et qu'il est certaine quand
même qu'ils aiment bien les mecs pas
forcément musclé et moi j'aime pas les
torses trop musclé tu vois je préfère
les torts sont normaux 100 muscle un
jour première fois de muscu préfère une
vraie sabra sur ce que serait que moi un
bon crémant mazel je peux vous prendre
une crème solaire pas bien sûr merci
c'est pour mettre sur vos oui c'est ça
attends attends ce cas là bas on sortait
ensemble
bon j'avoue c'est vrai que quand on
n'est pas forcément musclée
des fois on est un peu jaloux tu vois
on trouve des excuses mais ça va là ils
contractent c'est facile moi si je
contracte c'est pareil c'est vas-y
contracte mais je peux pas contracter
maintenant vous êtes facile ok je garde
ça sous contrat classé on a raté
contracte je contracte la banon moi j'ai
pas contracter c'est tout je pars à
contracter aujourd'hui après je
comprends c'est vrai qu'un torse musclé
c'est joli à regarder un mec ça peut
trouver les muscles ou d'un autre mec
bottois dans ce cas pas mal l'apec merci
bon après faut quand même qu'ils aient
des limites qu'elle était bienvenue chez
quand même ce mec a été vraiment
vraiment musclé quand même waouh je suis
comme ça c'est vrai que nous les mecs
pas musclé comme on est assez jaloux des
mecs musclés on aime bien dire ce genre
de phrase non mais c'est de la gonflette
ce n'est que là on sait tous que voilà
c'est bien beau ils ont des muscles mais
ils ont qu une force et non mais c'est
de la gonflette
le mec il n'a pas de force c'est un
éclair avec moi dès que l'été arrive
j'ai toujours envie d'être un peu musclé
sur la plage tu vois sauf que c'est trop
tard
total a dit j'ai pris là j'ai pris un
peu ouais t'as pris un coup de soleil
j'ai pris le pire toit ce qui m'énerve
vraiment le plus je crois c'est les mecs
qui sont musclés mais sans rien faire
alors eux ils font pas de muscu c'est
resté leurs corps dans les mecs qui sont
nés il était déjà d' un bébé muscles et
ça c'est naturel ouais d'accord les
toits c'est naturel aussi ah non moi ça
fait deux ans que je fais de la muscu la
moi je serai jamais musclée dans ma vie
je pense parce que voilà j'ai pas là
motif de faire la muscu c'est trop long
puis ça me correspond pas tu vois c'est
pas ma personnalité
moi je suis un mec pas musclé et je suis
bien comme ça tu as j'assume j'assume
pleinement mon corps ok ça va mal on
peut jouer au foot je te plaît c'est la
coupe du monde au fait ma page facebook
norman fait des vidéos vient de dépasser
les trois millions de j'aime ces
gigantesques merci à tous ça fait trop
plaisir
donc ça c'est les confettis ça
ciao c'est quoi la marque de ton
shampoing
alors si ça paie
white spirit pourquoi tu ne te présente
pas aux élections présidentielles parce
que si j'étais président de la
république tu as mon spectacle norman
sur scène commence à partir de septembre
en tournée dans toute la galaxie est
aussi à chalon sur saône pour venir me
voir cliquer sur le lien dans la
description